the maya
loom very large in our thinking and um
and are not as as frequent um players in
the book as originally this is you know
this we cover a lot of ground here and
this isn't that thick a book but here's
a little section on the maya from this
final chapter
in many regards the problems we are
facing now are ones we have faced before
every culture in human history has
engaged in both cooperation and
competition and behaved both in ways
that ought to make us proud to be human
and in those that make us ashamed
both glorious and ghastly actions have
been widespread
when looking back on history we have the
responsibility to recognize that truth
and also to recognize when our ancestors
wins legitimate or very often not have
provided us advantage that we did not
ourselves earn
it is not however our responsibility to
subjugate ourselves to those histories
europeans indeed stole land from native
americans and often grew some despicable
ways the native americans who were thus
subjugated themselves had a history of
warfare and conquest in the new world
taking land from one another
and of course none of this was new they
brought it with them to the new world
when they crossed over from beringia
many thousands of years earlier
let us not romanticize any people or
period let us instead understand
humanity holistically and work to
provide opportunity equally to everyone
going forward
in this book we have shared an
evolutionary toolkit with which to
understand the human condition not to
justify it
we are not served by ignoring what we
are
brutal apes by one measure we are not
served by oh we are also not served by
pretending that brutal apes are the only
thing that we are we are also generous
cooperative beings full of love
we have arrived in the 21st century with
evolutionary baggage and a fair bit of
intellectual confusion
let us understand the baggage in order
to reduce the confusion and increase our
odds of moving forward with maximal
human flourishing
as an aid to this end let us consider
the maya
the maya thrived for over two and a half
millennia and mesoamerica surviving
droughts and enemies and other
unpleasant extremes
in the now ancient city-states of the
maya including not just tikal but also
ekbalam chachuban and so many more stone
pyramids and temples are still visible
above the tops of the trees
on the forest floor footpaths run
between ancient buildings as do a
goodies lizards in the occasional ocelot
more substantial roads sock bays connect
city-states
most of the mayan city-states emerged as
political economic and cultural forces
to be reckoned with long before the
roman empire existed
wholly unaware of the other's existence
the maya and the romans were at their
peak at the same time in the early part
of the first millennium and both were an
obvious decline by the beginning of the
second
the maya had enlightenment of their own
long before the european enlightenment
we will never know its extent
we will never know its extent
as the vast majority of their books were
destroyed by europeans
the mayan civilization was spread widely
across the yucatan peninsula extending
south through modern belize in guatemala
and just barely dipping into honduras
the maya were dominant in these
landscapes for 2 500 years but they were
not monolithic and their successes waxed
and waned over both time and space
city-states collapsed droughts caused
the abandonment of once fertile lands
and while some areas were repopulated by
the maya others never were
the maya were intensive agriculturalists
who farmed on poor tropical soils but
managed to maintain soil fertility for a
remarkably long time through successful
land management
they dealt with the hilly slopes that
were ubiquitous throughout much of their
range with at least six types of
terracing systems
they used complex reservoirs to conserve
water during annual dry seasons and
during less predictable longer dry
spells
it is also true however
that where they cleaved cleared forests
the land was generally degraded and soil
quality fell
by the time the spaniards arrived the
maya were already in decline they had
had a long run and what exactly
precipitated their collapses up for
debate
while the mayan culture largely
disappeared the mayan people persist
they were not a fragile people or
culture they were robust and
long-standing
long-lasting one indication of just how
long a run they had is that they had a
unit of time the bactoon equal to 144
000 days almost 400 years they were so
long-lived as a people and so accustomed
to thinking across long time spans that
they use the baktun to help keep track
of time
the durability of the maya suggests that
the potential exists
that the potential exists for conscious
directed enlightenment in which we take
ownership of our own evolutionary state
like the maya we moderns need to find
ways to flatten the boom-bust cycle that
has plagued all populations across time
we hypothesized that the maya did this
by creating a mechanism for not turning
excess resources into more people or
ephemeral things
instead they invested in giant public
works projects
many of these public works projects are
visible today as temples as pyramids
they grew them like onions building more
layers in times of abundance in years of
plenty we posit when excess food could
easily have been turned into more people
which would have expanded the population
making hunger and conflict inevitable in
lean years the maya instead turned the
extra food into pyramids or into bigger
pyramids
they created glorious and useful public
spaces enjoyable by all and when
agricultural boom years inevitably
seeded to bust years the temples
required no nourishment and the
population could withstand the leaner
times
western civilization has been dominant
for nearly as long as the maya were
their culture unraveled accelerated at
the end by a hostile enemy from across
an ocean
our culture is unraveling as well
we need a new steady state an
evolutionarily stable strategy we need
to find the fourth frontier
and then we talk about obstacles and i
should say before i know you have things
to respond to in that um
the obstacles that we talk about to the
fourth frontier come from both the left
and the right and this is you know this
is an explicitly apolitical book in
which we identify ourselves as
politically liberal but liberals who can
identify the types of errors that
liberals the people on the left side of
the spectrum are more likely to make and
also identify the types of errors that
people on the right side of the spectrum
are more likely to make
and um and point out as has been pointed
out by many at other times but many
modern seem to have forgotten that we
need the tension that we need people on
both sides of a divide um as long as we
share basic fundamental values and a
belief in each other's humanity
the disagreeing about exactly where we
are and how to get to a better future um
makes for
the possibility of progress whereas
tamping down all dissent does not
yes and in fact i i think it makes sense
i still don't know how to make the point
so people hear it but
um
we are liberals but that is a
a measure of where we believe we are in
history it's not a fundamental
characteristic or a belief that
progress is inherently good right it's a
question of where we are and a
recognition that we cannot possibly stay
here just an even simple extrapolation
of how much resource we are using and
how many of us there are and what that
implies about the near term tells us
this is not
a an evolutionarily stable strategy that
we are currently engaged in and
therefore we have no choice but to
change but
the the point is and as you point out
this is something
enlightened conservatives agree on
which is that it is the tension between
the impulse to solve problems and a
healthy fear of the unintended
consequences of solution-making that
results in a society that functions and
does not constantly upend itself
with
naive errors
so
you know are we at the place where we
should all be progressives because
progress is absolutely required i think
so and maybe that's something you know
it will be interesting to see whether
that message from the book lands whether
people see
see that uh necessity
but the
those who would misunderstand you
intentionally
might hear
uh that any progress that is happening
is therefore good which of course is
absurd
and um and you know we could we could
i think accurately argue that so much of
the change that is happening now
certainly does not look like what
happened before and therefore could be
semantically called progress but is not
actually uh progressing us to anything
like a better future yeah it's like
progressing through time isn't the same
thing as progress in the way we mean it
yeah and unfortunately i think narrative
plays two roles that we haven't really
separated yet you and i both agree that
the way you move
people forward the way history moves
forward in the positive sense has to do
with compelling narratives not
compelling analyses nobody pays
attention
uh except for you know a small number of
people to orwell's
political philosophy right we pay
attention to 1984 because it makes the
point of that political philosophy in a
way that's very visceral so narrative
and it's easier to confuse people with
analysis and numbers and graphs um
precisely because
it's not native for for many people and
you know i think um
many especially you know like
intellectual elites media elites and
such um
actually seem to agree with the
widespread sentiment that just most
people are dumb most people can't take
it most people aren't interested and so
you just need to hand them pre-digested
pap
we don't we never have
and that was evident in our classrooms
but what i do
do believe and did see
is that most people
do not really think uh quantitatively
very well uh they don't think with
numbers very well and i believe that
having that as a as a weakness um
is
is runs hand in hand with therefore
being more easily uh confused and lied
to with those sorts of tools right
people i think they you know if you're
talking to an honest broker who knows
what they're talking about and they
present an analysis where you can't
quite follow the math but you can you
understand what the conclusion of it is
you're not in no danger but you're in
less danger but the problem is when you
have no idea who it is who's constructed
the analysis i mean this is this was the
point of how to lie with statistics
which is right for people who are in a
position to check the underlying logic
statistics are a place that you can vary
a lot of bodies
um so anyway narrative on the one hand
is the way you would move things forward
positively but we also live in a
landscape where
everything is basically subject to
official narratives that
do not appear to have our interests at
heart and so
you know surrendering to the idea that
narrative is perhaps the most important
thing but that it is also a landscape
that is uh ripe for abuse
is
maybe part of the
the tension of of our of our moment
um
did you have more to say there well i
did it did occur to me as you were
reading that section of the book that
may be one way um
to move at least one of our attentions
forward is to write
[Music]
a sequel
called something like um
the caterpillar who was unknowingly at
fault for his own hunger that that book
might actually bridge the divide between
these two narratives and we might be
able to move forward from there um pick
up some of the uh uh
what's it even forgot what the
caterpillar book is called um a very
hungry caterpillar like
picking up some of that audience well i
just don't think that this caterpillar
is entitled to be freed from all
responsibility for his predicament you
think his insatiability is his own doing
in one way or another i feel certain of
that yes
i do not remember the plot of the book
so i can't really know that that's i
mean the plot is just that he eats
everything but i don't remember the
conclusion
all right yeah i have the feeling it was
it's kind of thin on plot which is um
you know
true for a certain style of children's
books
it's then on plot okay i'm pretty sure
it's going to end with him turning i
mean i'd prefer it if it was a moth
right
um why
because it's more surprising but i have
the sense that that the caterpillar
probably turns into a beautiful diurnal
butterfly and uh lives happily ever
after for the next two weeks
or something like that yes it's true i'm
actually i don't know
um this is definitely the moment to get
into what we do and do not know about
lepidopteran biology right you and me or
science no no no yes so i don't know if
um
if actually it's if any adult
butterflies or moths lepidoctrins um
live
a long time
or even if um
if they will tend to live as long as
they spent as as larva the larval form
is often longer yeah
it varies a lot because the larval form
has so much resource accumulation to
make i think certain things like
sphincted moths are actually fairly long
lived you know we know a guy we will ask
our expert friend and absolutely
actually we should we should do a thing
on sphingid moths
are really fingers are sphinx moths um
gorgeous yeah they're beautiful
sometimes mistaken for hummingbirds
because of their flight agility
um are you serious yeah
i didn't know that yeah mistaken for
hummingbirds sure i think i may even
have done it once or twice you know okay
something flies by
but uh anyway they're
nocturnal so it's not so easy to confuse
them but there are moments in the day
when it can happen yeah and there is
actually as i mentioned at the top of
the hour uh some a section in the book
in which we ask um if a butterfly
remembers being a caterpillar um and the
answer is presumably not and there
wouldn't be much value value there
presumably not because there would be so
little value exactly exactly maybe just
these last three paragraphs sure of
the final chapter
before the epilogue before the afterward
before the acknowledgements glossary etc
etc
from the moment when our ancestors
achieved ecological dominance
competition competition between
populations has been our dominant
selective force
millions of years of evolution have
refined our circuitry for such
competition and it has become the
default at the human software level
now though three things conspire to make
the inclinations that brought us to this
moment an existential threat to our
future
the scale of the human population
the unprecedented power of the tools at
our disposal and the interconnectedness
of the systems on which we depend global
economy ecology and reach of technology
the importance of understanding human
software is urgent
the problem we face is the product of
evolutionary dynamics
all plausible solutions involve
awareness of those dynamics
the problem is evolutionary
so is the solution
[Music]